sie beten die geben
das duo wird endlich weg von den drogen
noch damit zum wiederholten mal
abgestürzt die stets nur eine klinik
die spielsüchtigen suisse verloren
damit ist sogar seinen job als pizza
kurier los
samira fitness süchtig und
schwarzstörche drei mal wagte ihres
ganzen erster ab sie trägt die klinik
muss jetzt lehrer wieder normal tasse
die alimente für andere quack versucht
ihnen ins lager klinik seehofers
burgdorf der retro wort ruft das ruft
notiert reto ist erstmal hier fabian
gerber pflegefachfrau in der klinik
der es gibt rot bevor das setup haut
wird
unter schock
[Musik]
ich denke administrativ nur einige
verfassen
jetzt kommt mit gehörten anfangs nur für
das problem drogen vom rohstoff
benzodiazepin macht ihn extrem
[Musik]
magazine strom ja ja ja ich weiß ich das
noch häufig soll das gilt auch wenn sie
den i tritt zutage tritt am info herr
yoo nervöser jene klappt man abstand
wollten sind und gerade mit der note
oder angst dass die neuen infocus kajo
das ist häufiges oder das soll aber mit
verursachen aber das zimmer 237 unter
den kollegen aus da habe ich sofort noch
einfacher
[Musik]
und so
deshalb statisch arbeitslos und online
spielte sich ins leben zurück kämpfen
sie erst die vorsatz mehr sport
[Musik]
unter auch erwin sowieso
ihr frühes zweimal in europa zu spüren
der schuss kam
nach dem wortlaut von gehen wir mit
ihren jüngsten friedensweg das spiel
spielen
ein
[Musik]
sport ist aber nicht gemacht für zeit
erwartet der beschäftigung wird inhalt
waren erste schritte seiner spielsucht
mit alten zyklus geht es darum wieder
zur stelle vermutlich mit bier brief vom
straßenverkehrsamt wie der begriff der
autofahrer müsse dafür roses für
unbestimmte zeit
die hiobsbotschaft gehört sie bereits
zum ersten mal das heißt wir die nächste
das nächste halbjahr ist orientiert für
erstellen als chauffeur gestorben
das war ja wie gesagt habe ich so
wenigstens eine pierburg stunden zu
nehmen
was können sie sich vorstellen was sich
andere ich arbeite findet erledigen was
während der sakristei und wir wurden so
tankstellen des öko und die fans
schrieben ziemlich bewerbungen für die
stelle und energie miteinander andere
erfahrungen
okay das war es meine zielgruppe mir
deine liebe zählt ist er sich also job
zu fressen berichten virus ist so ein
ding das ich und mir noch länger vor
gericht kommt dazu führen dass wir für
heroes ist zurück ich denke das gesetz
ich der richtige mann für alles
dass er sich jetzt haben wir sind für
mich ganz neu und entsprechen sind beim
gesprächen nicht wirklich wie die hosen
sind einfach immer wieder dem fuß
abgehackt perspektive sehe perspektiven
sieht muss das land jetzt kriege ich mit
aus ökologisch aufwendung bezirke hat
die beiden pizza kurier mit ihnen
geschafft haben damit drei punkte für
uns los ist studiert stelleninserat für
chauffeur james
wo immer unterwegs so wie meine stadt
autofahrern darum sich so eine show
passt freut mich also meine stadt fahren
[Musik]
zwei wochen jetzt in die klinik war weit
dass er sich therapieren viel
profitabler hund postieren und die
komische grimasse woods im iran herrscht
noch massive ausfälle vom protokoll
torkamera wieder die bsi ja ich musste
was ich nicht kann verdammt alle und ja
ich das immer schwierig gefühle vor dem
essen und nach dem essen kann sich
amerika und sicherheit
susanne lo sie also zur latzhose und
sophia ries fleisch kasse und ich ein
urteil auf die von reese kasse
samira falsch wäre ein exploit
akzeptiere
über den berg ist die frau schnitt
später unter rückschlag
es ist immer nur fleiß und ganz hinter
druck zu heißen und ja ich ziemlich
nacht-u-bahn forums mittag ein etwas und
kann nicht einfach an und will auch
könig ich weiß es ist bullshit
und auch heute zu schlagen mit ihrer
therapeutin hat samir auch jede klinik
über die situation reden
dass das keine offizielle sie das
manchmal gut läuft und denke mal wieder
mit wieviel und dass sie unsicher sind
sechs richtigen ist nicht extrem
das heißt es ist nicht abhängig von dem
gewicht oder so wie sie sich fühle
also ganz praktisches know-how
problematik
einen anderen bezug das ist nicht so
eine zwang und dachte ich das ist
absolut woche einen tag krank sind dann
trainieren und denn ich kann und ich
finde ja weil sie lachen aber das gar
nicht nachstehen
die innere prozess dass das die selbst
ans ufer war bin ich überhaupt zu der
eigene halten sich finde das sind themen
die begleitet haben sid haben sie das
kind ist aber die die hand der
urspringer schon in der frühen kindheit
und die haben nicht von heute auf morgen
einfach so andere aber das braucht zeit
die klinik muss ich zu mir als war alex
plan halten und sie darf nun also viel
trainieren wie früher
aber wenn sie darf verbringt sie jede
freie minute mit sport
ich war fünf jahre lang
so unsichtbar gemacht hat und den
eigentlich gar nicht erlauben hat dann
ist es sehr sehr schwierig vorbehaltlos
zu und sagen das macht gar keinen grund
[Musik]
der rhetorisch mittlerweile knapp die
wutrede klinik sie in drogerie
drittstaat eine erste standortbestimmung
auf dem programm
[Musik]
wir haben versucht mit da muss ich
natürlich schon an dieser stelle der
verschiedenen bands hofft dass das ist
ja jetzt auch eines pendlers braucht
weil dir einfach mit auch bands
das wusste die verschiedenen besser
aussieht das 100 fahren vor dem start
kam tommy komplex oder kokain und
cannabis das quasi zander und umstellung
auf substanzen prominenten zu machen
damit und das ist jetzt vorbei
das heißt es geht schon stabile
blutspender sofort und damit sieht sich
jetzt der ganze langsam flat xs vorteile
energie und bieten sprechern der ruhe
wenn man die richtige dosis heizung und
das duldet sie mit jetzt mal dran
demir morgen mein stabilisiere
ungeliebte mit dem rebound zum elften
mal macht reto wir jetzt entzug erfolg
mittag problem größte sich mit den
worten suchte sie mir sagen einen sehr
coolen immer wieder darunter die drei
hunde zu rufen spirale wird und nicht
wie so häufig zur arbeit spielen rät
weiß dass die nächsten tage schwierig
wartet und nicht nur die
und da soll noch kennen vor augen eine
kleine ortschaften gemeldet wo dann
vergleicht sie als erinnerungsstück
schaffte der allied können wenn es wohl
ab und das ist vor gott das ist ja nicht
aus da die bedeutung und das team
[Musik]
und zum afa die fans simon
bei vier bis sechs mal die woche besucht
samira verschiedene therapiestunde
wieder krank entspannen sie sich
möglichst wohlfühlen bei der therapie
mit alpaka
[Gelächter]
wie die grundsteuer oder
bewegungstherapie gar zum positiven zu -
der lehre sich selber wieder zu
akzeptieren und zu macht man natürlich
erstmal was ich aber war verletzt ich
schon seine richtigkeit habe dass sie
zum beispiel zwei mal wieder hochkommen
100 prozent von butter und zucker
versuch mal luft ich habe mir eine
flasche zu mir einen fortschritt gemacht
jetzt laut sie sich sogar die alte
gewohnheit aber nicht abgeleitet zu
setzen wie spielte blieb trocken
[Musik]
ja aber gerade für mich jetzt darauf an
dass sich dieses mal nicht dafür weiß
ich aber wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel
stammt bin oder so habe ich das problem
die soße sasse
solange das nicht der fall ist nur
wenige tag und er hat samira wieder rein
[Musik]
massiv ist image von kriegen
der retro gespürt zum ersten mal seit
langem wieder wie sich ohne drogen
[Musik]
ja also wir geschafft dann brauchen sie
ist gelernte metallbauer und zur job für
noch die klinik er weiß dass er
beschäftigung braucht wenn er nach muss
tritt nicht wieder rückfällig
acht verschiedene therapie mit grund
therapien argument für u2 kreta
aber man kann ja der große situation
überschätzt und nach alter und nachher
aufbringt und disziplin oder früchtetees
und die damen für die kniescheibe drauf
begriff von allen klar stellt jeder
klinik ist das nun drehte weiß aber dass
es böse wieder anders rossi
die auf ihr buch ich jetzt einiges 37
dank das schon so komisch wenn ihr
content wie die ruhe kommen und nicht
erreicht
[Musik]
jeder pizzeria kenterte chef persönlich
weiter web ist für mich der taktiker der
nazis slawische freund von der familie
das taxiunternehmen und dem jc
versprochen dass er die augen offen
halten für ihn
weil das pc portiert der betagten
ehepaar der taz zu werden
die fahrschule zu fahrschule sind dazu
ständig ist ja doch sexy aber im moment
habe bildungsmäßig dass der produkt
einmal lust auf mehr
wenn der job wieder aufhören mit
cannabis konsumieren wenn es sich für
uns zurück muss er nämlich das halbjahr
wurden proben
[Musik]
sportexperte illegal internetcafé die
eigentlich sucht meldet sich zurück
spielt verspielt das ganze geld für drei
monate ein einziger blick
[Musik]
780 das alles untersuchen
das knapp ich alles fürs ganze monat 280
bis 360 euro verbuchen müssten
der kollege eine schule müsste eine 200
andere 200 und das mit 187 kann ich das
nur eines führerscheines zahlen
großgewinn kopf wie man ohne erfolg
zweiter wirklich wirklich fassen weiß
man immer was man machen
er macht seinen in seine mitte macht
jetzt das mit 647
jetzt fordert die smart grid arrays ist
dass du jetzt noch spielt
sie merkt sofort dass ich macht die
heimat sie hat ja gar nicht war es sie
heißt was sich auf die ökonomie
kommunizieren was sie mag das
[Musik]
regula für damit ich mich weil ich
zeigen kann
ich mache immer wieder konnte das know
how und da bin ich auch selbst froh und
sehr stolz drauf und das trotzdem
schlecht für mich
nach drei matches amira ihre letzte tag
im stoff enthält
[Musik]
im internet sind sie selbst sehr sexy
und jetzt ist kritisch 50,2
ja wenn er doch das stimmt dass ich doch
so eine normale ernährung sage ich jetzt
mal klappt dann so das gericht und der
handel sind verloren
dame mit ihrer therapeutin lozano bis 11
so kann sie heute der große tag
wie gut seine denn gut was haben sie
denn jetzt offiziell für die nächste tag
also für die nachschub gesichert oder
sich der heime des aufenthaltes
suchanbieter führer respektiv dass ich
nicht wieder das kontroll freak gehen
und alles ab werke und ganz genau
notieren und und strecke und ich weiß
etwas
der nachteil ist dass sie denn einmal
sich selber lacht viel druck machen und
wie wird das mit der disziplin das ist
so viel wie nie das und ich wünschte mir
aber viel weniger aber ich muss sagen
ich egal ist die weise luft an und hören
erinnert und sich kreis problem und
werden diese klinik sind auch
freundschaften entstanden und die zwei
abschiede
ja
mittels spiegel und alles
[Musik]
sie geht zwar weiter in die kliniken
therapiestunde ob sie wohnt wieder der
heime und nicht wieder brandort ich
darüber wie sie ist und trainiert
schlimmste wäre wenn ich jetzt wieder
packen wir kannten so bekommt das ist ja
das lässt sich das wetter so strikt
heute wieder anfange sachen über längere
zeit extrem verbieten und den usa hat
das eigentlich für mich jetzt so ein
moment
[Musik]
dorit zinn austritt stock
der ethikrat auf eigenen wunsch wieder
heim
aber es ist eine chance und kleider bei
raus und gut und hätten dem euro bevor
[Musik]
ja
als ruhegeld ob sie als ist nur eins
dreht der heime und über und als erste
gute nachricht
details zu seinen wurzeln und konnte zu
riesig
ich bin ich nicht am lexus samstag
samira fall zurück die mutter bemerkte
ich muss es nicht
sie lebte behandeln ließen